Alice:收一下
Alice: Clean up.
Jake: 哎还是给我袋
Jake: Hey, give me a bag.
Jake: 我还是拿袋子
Jake: I'll take the bag.
Tasha: 不是说好一起收拾的吗
Tasha: Didn't we agree to clean up together?
Tasha: 客户在
Tasha: The client is here.
Alice: 先搁哪
Alice: Where should we put this?
Alice: 这个要不先给他搁一边吧
Alice: How about we put it aside for now?
Alice: 碍事
Alice: It's in the way.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:扔那吧
Jake: Just throw it there.
Alice:有那个铝铝的
Alice: There's that aluminum thing.
Jake: 架子上这个帮我挪一下啊
Jake: Move this thing on the shelf for me, will you?
Jake: 呃回头点再弄
Jake: Uh, let's do it later.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Okay.
Jake: 就这个板
Jake: Just this board.
Alice:这个板
Alice: This board?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 私密马赛
Alice: Sumimasen (Excuse me).
Tasha: 哇大西不是故意的
Tasha: Wow, Daxi didn't do it on purpose.
Alice: 哇大西不是故意的
Alice: Wow, Daxi didn't do it on purpose.
Alice: 妈妈桑
Alice: Mama-san.
Alice: 哈哈妈妈酱妈妈咪呀
Alice: Haha, mama-san, mama mia.
Alice: 这个先给他搁冰箱上吧
Alice: Let's just put it on the fridge for now.
Alice: 我真的想戴上个手套说实话
Alice: Honestly, I really want to put on some gloves.
Tasha: 那可以戴那个无菌手套
Tasha: You can wear the sterile gloves.
Alice:不还得下去拿
Alice: But we have to go downstairs to get them.
Tasha: 收拾
Tasha: Clean up.
Alice: 算了哎呦
Alice: Never mind, ouch.
Katrina: 打一套醉拳呐
Katrina: Doing some drunken boxing?
Alice:谁的酱这么稠
Alice: Whose sauce is this thick?
Shure:  完了你的福根被倒掉了
Shure: Oh no, your axe got knocked over.
Shure:  也没有福了
Shure: And there's no axe left.
Katrina:  太好了哇菜刀
Katrina: Great, wow, a kitchen knife.
Shure:  比划两下
Shure: Try a few moves.
Katrina: 菜刀怎么会出现在这里
Katrina: How did this kitchen knife end up here?
Katrina:  给你舞一个
Katrina: Let me dance with it.
Katrina:  自己刀哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Dance with my own knife, hahaha.
Katrina:  这油倒哪呢
Katrina: Where should I pour this oil?
Tasha: 那
Tasha: There.
Shure:  为什么拿他晒
Shure: Why are you sunbathing with him?
Shure:  给你倒的酒你没有喝
Shure: The drink I poured for you, you didn't drink it.
Tasha: 我喝了
Tasha: I did drink it.
Tasha: 你好会扭哦
Tasha: You're so good at twisting.
Katrina:  倒倒倒哪来的
Katrina: Pour, pour, where did it come from?
Shure:  我来倒吧
Shure: I'll pour it.
Shure:  我来倒我来倒
Shure: I'll pour it, I'll pour it.
Katrina:  倒麻酱里
Katrina: Pour it into the sesame paste.
Tasha: 对先倒到这吧
Tasha: Yes, pour it here first.
Katrina:  小时候我给老鼠做老鼠药就这样
Katrina: When I was a kid, I made rat poison just like this.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Shure:  还做这个呢
Shure: Still doing this?
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh my gosh
Katrina: 风油精花露水
Katrina: Essential balm and floral water
Katrina:  加一点好吃的饼干
Katrina: Add some tasty cookies
Katrina:  哎我看有没有那个塑料袋
Katrina: Hey, let me see if we have a plastic bag
Katrina:  我们直接扔了
Katrina: We'll just throw it away
Shure:  你觉得我
Shure: Do you think I
Shure:  我明天这瓶我觉得就可以喝完了
Shure: I think I can finish this bottle by tomorrow
Katrina:  哈哈哈再说你你就这样拿
Katrina: Hahaha, just take it like this
Tasha: 天呐噢
Tasha: Oh my god
Katrina:  就那天迎宾的时候
Katrina: When we were welcoming guests that day
Tasha: 老板居然干最辛苦的活
Tasha: The boss actually did the hardest work
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed
Tasha: 哎这个盆边好脏
Tasha: Hey, the edge of this basin is so dirty
Shure:  哎呀
Shure: Oh dear
Katrina: 咱不是有几个盒马的袋子吗
Katrina: Don't we have some bags from Hema?
Katrina:  噢我有泸溪河的
Katrina: Oh, I have some from Luxihe
Katrina: 泸溪河的袋子
Katrina: Luxihe's bags
Shure: 我给你们俩加油
Shure: I'll cheer you both on
Shure:  加油加油
Shure: Go, go, go
Katrina:  这谁的呀
Katrina: Whose is this?
Tasha: 来干活吧
Tasha: Come on, let's get to work
Alice:哦他刚开的
Alice: Oh, he just opened it
Tasha: 修硕
Tasha: Shure
Tasha: 我教您
Tasha: I'll teach you
Tasha: 您就把这个
Tasha: You just have to
Shure: 我不听加油加油加油我不听
Shure: I'm not listening, go, go, go, I'm not listening
Shure:  加油加油哈哈哈
Shure: Go, go, hahaha
Katrina:  你今天晚上任务是负责把
Katrina: Your task tonight is to
Katrina:  yes OK
Katrina: yes OK
Katrina:  学会明天教我们
Katrina: Learn it and teach us tomorrow
Shure:  我我我今天晚上负负责喝的死死的
Shure: I'm, I'm, I'm just going to drink myself silly tonight
Shure:  然后睡觉
Shure: Then sleep
Katrina:  Lucy和儿子太像了呀
Katrina: Lucia looks so much like her son
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh my gosh
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no
Shure:  酒精大学四年怎么过来的
Shure: How did I get through four years of college with alcohol
Katrina:  哎苦学生
Katrina: Oh, poor student
Katrina:  嘘又被我撞到了
Katrina: Shh, I bumped into it again
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈嘘
Katrina: Hahahaha shhh
Katrina:  大学四年都干什么啊
Katrina: What did you do during the four years of college?
Katrina:  忘了感觉保研之后才真正大学生活
Katrina: I forgot, it feels like only after getting the postgraduate recommendation did I really start college life.
Katrina:  但是我感觉我也没有那种特别
Katrina: But I feel like I didn't have that kind of intense studying.
Katrina:  就是学的特别吓人的那种
Katrina: You know, the kind that scares you.
Katrina:  就是期末周去那种
Katrina: Like during finals week.
Katrina:  主要我们班
Katrina: Mainly because our class...
Katrina:  我们班保研率很高保
Katrina: Our class had a high rate of postgraduate recommendations.
Alice:装不下
Alice: Can't fit anymore.
Katrina:  然后运气特别好
Katrina: And we were really lucky.
Katrina:  然后一般就是我们年级这个实验班
Katrina: Usually, this experimental class in our grade...
Katrina:  他是需要竞争
Katrina: It requires competition.
Katrina:  大一分流的时候竞争进去
Katrina: You have to compete to get in during freshman year.
Alice:还有袋没了
Alice: There's no more bags left.
Katrina:  我们那一年没人报你知道吗
Katrina: That year no one applied, you know?
Alice:还有袋没了
Alice: There's no more bags left.
Katrina:  然后我绩点那么低我都进了
Katrina: My GPA was so low, but I still got in.
Katrina:  然后我就保研了
Katrina: And then I got the postgraduate recommendation.
Alice: 这俩是谁的
Alice: Whose are these two?
Alice:还喝吗
Alice: Are you still drinking?
Tasha: 好像都不喝了
Tasha: Seems like no one is.
Alice: 那我倒了
Alice: Then I'll dump it.
Katrina:  我人生很搞笑的我感觉
Katrina: My life is so funny, I feel.
Shure:  东北孩子都会唱刀郎
Shure: All kids from the northeast can sing Dao Lang's songs.
Katrina: 呀呀呀还有没有
Katrina: Hey, hey, hey, is there any more?
Katrina: 好恶心
Katrina: So gross.
Shure:  你好恶心
Shure: You're disgusting.
Katrina:  麻酱no
Katrina: Sesame paste, no.
Shure:  麻酱no
Shure: Sesame paste, no.
Katrina: yes no
Katrina: Yes, no.
Shure:  然后醋yes
Shure: And vinegar, yes.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Katrina:  狂加醋
Katrina: Add a lot of vinegar.
Jake: 嘿卢亚呢
Jake: Hey, where's Luya?
Shure:  卢亚已经睡着了吧
Shure: Luya is probably asleep already.
Shure:  可能
Shure: Maybe.
Katrina:  真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Jake:卢亚带个眼镜呗
Jake: Luya, put on some glasses.
Katrina:  他喝酒了吗
Katrina: Did he drink?
Shure:  他喝了一碗
Shure: He drank a bowl.
Jake: 一碗
Jake: One bowl.
Katrina: 完了
Katrina: Done.
Shure:  我们要不晚上再来一局吧
Shure: How about we play another round tonight?
Katrina:  哈哈晚上再来一局
Katrina: Haha, another round tonight.
Katrina:  就直接给你掏心掏肺讲故事了
Katrina: I'll pour my heart out and tell you stories.
Shure:  哈哈哈我就要听掏心掏肺讲故事哎
Shure: Haha, I just want to hear those heartfelt stories.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you.
Shure:  其实其实酒桌上掏心掏肺讲故事
Shure: Honestly, telling heartfelt stories at the table...
Shure:  第二天第二另另外几个人都记不住
Shure: The next day, no one remembers them.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Shure:  哈哈哈掏心掏肺讲完了你你很爽
Shure: Haha, you pour your heart out, and you feel great.
Shure:  然后其他人也很爽
Shure: And everyone else feels great too.
Shure:  但是大家都记不住这个事
Shure: But no one remembers the stories.
Shure:  情就很很很爽
Shure: It's just a great feeling.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Katrina:  对爽了就行
Katrina: Yeah, as long as it feels good.
Shure:  这大家只走一个过程
Shure: It's all about the experience.
Katrina:  真好呀主要我当时我舍友都特别乖
Katrina: That's awesome. My roommates were so well-behaved back then.
Katrina:  没人提议说去酒吧
Katrina: No one ever suggested going to a bar.
Shure:  也不一定非去酒吧呀
Shure: You don't necessarily have to go to a bar.
Shure:  先喝酒吧
Shure: Just drink first.
Katrina:  他们不喝
Katrina: They don't drink.
Katrina:  哎呦喝一瓶RIO就倒了
Katrina: Oh, they get drunk after one bottle of RIO.
Katrina: crazy
Katrina: Crazy.
Jake: 这边都不够
Jake: This isn't enough.
Jake: 要不带点下去吃
Jake: How about taking some to eat downstairs?
Jake: 再带一个吧
Jake: Take another one.
Jake: 碗下去洗吧要不
Jake: How about washing the bowl downstairs?
Jake: 这边够了
Jake: This is enough here.
Shure:  加油加油加油加油加
Shure: Keep going, keep going, keep going.
Katrina: 你跳那个
Katrina: You jump that.
Alice: 这边这还有
Alice: There's more over here.
Choiszt: 呃等会你先别扔这个先把这个拿下
Choiszt: Uh, wait a minute, don't throw that yet, take this first.
Alice:这个
Alice: This one?
Katrina:  什么cheerbaby
Katrina: What's "cheerbaby"?
Lucia: 我的房间也好了
Lucia: My room is ready too.
Katrina:  你就在旁边cheer
Katrina: You just cheer on the side.
Katrina:  babycheer
Katrina: Baby cheer.
Shure: 你还会跳
Shure: You can dance too.
Alice:哦这个先不用
Alice: Oh, we don't need this right now.
Alice: 等一下
Alice: Wait a minute.
Shure:  啊你也会跳这个是吗
Shure: Oh, you can dance this too?
Katrina:  会啊高中的时候不是可流行的吗
Katrina: Yeah, it was so popular back in high school.
Alice:应该就没啥了
Alice: There shouldn't be anything else.
Jake: 啥呀
Jake: What is it?
Alice:把这小渣渣扔进去
Alice: Throw this little trash in.
Shure: 好东西
Shure: Good stuff.
Jake: 哦会跳这个
Jake: Oh, you can dance this.
Jake: 因为我我以前我在美国
Jake: Because I, I used to be in America.
Jake: 那个房东的小孩
Jake: The landlord's kid.
Jake: 就天天在我面前秀这个
Jake: Used to show off this every day in front of me.
Tasha: 这个水是用这个是洗不掉的
Tasha: This water won't wash it off.
Jake: 那用什么
Jake: Then what should we use?
Alice:没有了
Alice: Nothing else.
Tasha: 用他抹
Tasha: Use this to wipe it.
Katrina:  也年轻过
Katrina: We've all been young.
Shure:  也年轻过
Shure: We've all been young.
Shure:  谁没年轻过呢是吧
Shure: Who hasn't been young, right?
Tasha: 要吗
Tasha: Want it?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Choiszt: 带个手套吧
Choiszt: Put on a glove.
Katrina:  你看我站在这里
Katrina: Look at me standing here.
Katrina:  其实我已经走了一会
Katrina: Actually, I've been walking for a while.
Jake: 这个碗
Jake: This bowl.
Katrina: 你看我站在这里
Katrina: Look at me standing here.
Katrina:  其实我已经走了一会
Katrina: Actually, I've been walking for a while.
Shure:  哲学你懂吗
Shure: Do you understand philosophy?
Shure:  他虽然就是形态站在这
Shure: He's physically standing here.
Shure:  但是意识已经走了
Shure: But his mind has already left.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 这还有个男呃好吧他走了
Tasha: There's also a guy, uh, okay he's gone.
Katrina:  酒量测试开始
Katrina: Drinking test begins.
Katrina:  这怎么洗呢
Katrina: How to wash this?
Katrina:  能拿厨房湿巾吗
Katrina: Can we use kitchen wipes?
Jake: 这要不放下面洗
Jake: Should we wash it below?
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or
Tasha: 就就在这洗吧
Tasha: Just wash it here.
Tasha: 你可以换一张抹布了
Tasha: You can change a rag.
Lucia: 更方便洗一些
Lucia: It's easier to wash.
Jake:还还能用
Jake: It can still be used.
Lucia: 这能先擦一遍吗
Lucia: Can I wipe this first?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Alice: 这个不用待会直接洗洁精洗就行了
Lucia: 感觉里面很多渣
Lucia: Feels like there's a lot of residue inside.
Lucia: 有的把它先弄出来
Lucia: Let's get it out first.
Lucia: 刚那个不是有点
Lucia: Wasn't there a bit just now?
Lucia: 稍微有点
Lucia: A little bit.
Lucia: 那个啥有点堵
Lucia: It was a bit clogged.
Tasha: 这汤好鲜美啊
Tasha: This soup is so delicious.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 你确实
Tasha: You really...
Shure:  我给你们打call
Shure: I'm cheering for you guys.
Jake: 你说的真的
Jake: Are you serious?
Katrina:  你喝什么呢
Katrina: What are you drinking?
Shure:  啤啤酒
Shure: Beer.
Shure:  尝一尝吧
Shure: Try some.
Katrina:  不要了
Katrina: No, thanks.
Katrina:  再那个我都害怕
Katrina: If I drink more, I'll be scared.
Shure:  你干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure:  哈哈他妈的
Shure: Haha, damn it.
Tasha: 我帮你扔掉
Tasha: I'll throw it away for you.
Jake: 谢谢您哎
Jake: Thank you.
Alice: 没事这可能是他的陈年污渍
Alice: No worries, it might be his old stain.
Lucia: 对擦了擦感觉掉不了
Lucia: Yeah, it doesn't seem to come off even after wiping.
Lucia: 不管他那个了
Lucia: Forget about it then.
Tasha: 前天还好买了一包吧
Tasha: Luckily, I bought a pack the day before yesterday.
Alice: 这个锅原来在二楼吗
Alice: Was this pot originally on the second floor?
Lucia: 这个这个锅吗
Lucia: This pot?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 我也我也不太确定
Lucia: I'm not really sure.
Alice: 这是我们的还是这的
Alice: Is this ours or does it belong here?
Lucia: 这些锅应该都是这儿的
Lucia: These pots should all belong here.
Alice: 那放二楼吧
Alice: Then let's put it on the second floor.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: Whatever.
Shure:  我觉得
Shure: I think...
Shure:  是时候拿出吉他了
Shure: It's time to bring out the guitar.
Alice: 来放一下锅
Alice: Let's protect the pot.
Tasha: 嗯放这吧
Tasha: Hmm, put it here.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Tasha: 好像锅也就能放哦锅还没洗
Tasha: Seems like the pot can fit... oh, the pot hasn't been washed yet.
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Shure:  洗手间
Shure: Bathroom.
Shure:  帅老师不喜欢回归大自然吗
Shure: Doesn't Mr. Handsome like returning to nature?
Alice: 这谁的呀
Alice: Whose is this?
Tasha: 这个是我的
Tasha: This is mine.
Tasha: 但是我没喝完嘛
Tasha: But I haven't finished drinking it.
Alice: 那我给你留这了啊
Alice: Then I'll leave it here for you.
Tasha: 好行
Tasha: Okay, sure.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Shure:  你喝吗啊
Shure: Are you drinking it?
Tasha: 我喝呢
Tasha: I'm drinking it.
Shure: 你真喝吗
Shure: Really drinking it?
Tasha: 真喝呢
Tasha: Really drinking it.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 你喝一杯应该没关系吧
Tasha: You having a cup should be fine, right?
Shure:  喝一杯他
Shure: Having a cup of it...
Shure:  他毫无关系
Shure: It doesn't matter at all.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice: 醋放下边
Alice: Put the vinegar below.
Tasha: 行啊
Tasha: Sure.
Shure:  没事这这这柜里还有3瓶呢
Shure: No worries, there are three more bottles in this cabinet.
Tasha: 你怎么不购入一台
Tasha: Why don't you buy one?
Tasha: 买一个小碗洗碗机吧
Tasha: Buy a small dishwasher.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 我们有硕
Jake: We have Shure.
Alice: 还有垃圾吗
Alice: Any more trash?
Tasha: 硕硕
Tasha: Shure, Shure.
Jake: 来一轮
Jake: One more round.
Tasha: 没了
Tasha: No more.
Alice: 没了
Alice: No more.
Lucia: 这个可以当垃圾袋用
Lucia: This can be used as a trash bag.
Lucia: 因为里面扔了很多
Lucia: Because there's already a lot thrown in here.
Shure:  what's up bro
Shure: What's up, bro?
Tasha: 让你买个洗碗机
Tasha: Telling you to buy a dishwasher.
Jake:让你当个洗碗机
Jake: Telling you to be a dishwasher.
Tasha: 让你当个洗碗机
Tasha: Telling you to be a dishwasher.
Shure:  让我买个洗碗机
Shure: Let me buy a dishwasher.
Jake: 买个是难
Jake: Buying one is hard.
Tasha: 让你当一个洗碗机
Tasha: Make you into a dishwasher.
Shure: 什么买个洗碗机
Shure: What, buy a dishwasher?
Jake: 当个洗碗机
Jake: Be a dishwasher.
Shure:  我靠买个洗碗机
Shure: Damn, buy a dishwasher.
Shure:  真的吗bro
Shure: Really, bro?
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 堵住了你有没有发现需要您清理
Tasha: It's clogged, have you noticed? You need to clean it.
Tasha: 这筷子洗的
Tasha: These chopsticks are washed.
Tasha: 我去真有水平
Tasha: Wow, so well done.
Shure:  跟洗跟没洗的一样
Shure: They look the same as unwashed.
小薇 你看他这个筷子洗的
Tasha: Look at his chopsticks.
Tasha: 洗成两坨了
Tasha: They're washed into two lumps.
Shure:  哎呦卧槽
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake: 跟没洗的一样
Jake: They look the same as unwashed.
Tasha: 我真受不了了
Tasha: I can't take it anymore.
Shure:  一看就是在家
Shure: You can tell it's at home.
Shure:  一天天娇生惯养的孩子们
Shure: Kids these days are so pampered.
Jake: 可拉倒吧
Jake: Oh, come on.
Jake: 谁在家呢
Jake: Who's at home?
Shure:  请问在在Singapore
Shure: Are they in Singapore?
Shure:  娇生惯养的孩子
Shure: Pampered kids.
Jake: 那也没在在Singapore也不在家待着
Jake: Even if they're in Singapore, they're not staying at home.
Shure:  哎我搅一会吧
Shure: Let me stir for a bit.
Shure:  然后先让他水流下去
Shure: Then let the water flow down.
Jake:我这先搁哪呢
Jake: Where should I put this first?
Shure:  你随便搁哪都行
Shure: Just put it anywhere.
Shure:  然后我搅一会就行
Shure: Then I'll stir for a bit.
Shure:  你别搁搁地漏上就行
Shure: Just don't put it on the drain.
Jake: 我先去洗洗手去
Jake: I'll wash my hands first.
Shure:  哎愁死了
Shure: I'm so worried.
Tasha: 哈哈哈洗碗机成功
Tasha: Hahaha, the dishwasher succeeded.
Shure:  ai看到了吗
Shure: Did you see that?
Shure:  就是人类搅一圈之后
Shure: After a human stirs it,
Shure:  手上会有这么多油
Shure: There's so much grease on their hands.
Shure:  你记住了吗
Shure: Did you remember?
Lucia: 你记住了吗
Lucia: Did you remember?
Shure:  侮辱杨老板的数据石吧
Shure: Insulting Jake's data stone.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Tasha: 这越洗越油
Tasha: The more I wash, the oilier it gets.
Tasha: 不要用另一只手摸他了
Tasha: Don't touch it with your other hand.
Tasha: 你拿那个湿巾擦一擦
Tasha: Use that wet wipe to clean it up.
Shure:  这样
Shure: Like this.
Alice: 这洗好了吗
Alice: Is it clean now?
Tasha: 这还要再冲一遍呢
Tasha: It needs another rinse.
Tasha: 这只用洗洁精抹了一遍
Tasha: This has just been wiped with dish soap once.
Alice: 是呢
Alice: Right.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice: 刚洗的手
Alice: Just washed my hands.
Shure:  有那锡纸锅两块钱一个哈哈
Shure: Those aluminum foil pots are two bucks each, haha.
Tasha: 你就是专业干这个的呀
Tasha: You're a pro at this.
Tasha: 怪不得喊你来当洗碗机呢
Tasha: No wonder they call you the dishwasher.
Lucia: 这边我觉得还是
Lucia: Over here, I think...
Tasha: 需要帮忙吗
Tasha: Need any help?
Lucia: 这太高了吧
Lucia: This is too high.
Lucia: 放下来一点
Lucia: Lower it a bit.
Tasha: 这个还要再冲一遍了
Tasha: This needs another rinse.
Alice: 你手串是开过光的吗
Alice: Is your bracelet blessed?
Alice: 你那手串开过光吗
Shure:  没有女朋友随便送我的
Shure: No, a girlfriend gave it to me casually.
Tasha: 肯定是他不要的哈哈哈
Tasha: It must be something she didn't want, haha.
Shure:  我就你会说话是不是
Shure: You're really good at talking, huh?
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  你信不信我这这盘子抡你脑袋上
Shure: Do you believe I'll hit you with this plate?
Tasha: 你说随便送东西的
Tasha: You said it was given casually.
Tasha: 肯定是她淘汰下来的货
Tasha: Must be something she eliminated.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  因为我平时平时穿粉色衣服多
Shure: Because I usually wear pink clothes.
Shure:  然后送我一个粉色手串
Shure: Then she gave me a pink bracelet.
Tasha: 哦你早说嘛
Tasha: Oh, you should've said so earlier.
Tasha: 是她特地送给你的不就行了
Tasha: So she specially gave it to you, right?
Tasha: 你为什么说是随便送给你的
Tasha: Why did you say it was given casually?
Alice: 要轻描淡写过去这个话题哈哈哈
Alice: Just brush over this topic lightly, haha.
Tasha: 然后还说要打我
Tasha: And then he said he wanted to hit me.
Alice: 哎我手机呢
Shure:  把杯子先都刷出来了
Shure: Let's wash all the cups first.
Shure:  因为杯子啊
Shure: Because the cups...
Shure:  啊对于喝酒
Shure: Are very important for drinking.
Shure:  来说很重要所以要都刷出来
Shure: So we need to wash them all.
Shure:  这本来就有杯子
Shure: There's already a cup here.
Shure:  咱们都使完了你知道吗
Shure: We've used them all up, you know?
Lucia: 不是我是说
Lucia: No, I mean,
Lucia: 就是我没看到有刷完需要擦的杯子
Lucia: I didn't see any cups that needed wiping after washing.
Lucia: 就是你这不是正刷着吗
Lucia: I mean, aren't you washing them right now?
Shure:  行了我刷了我刷了
Shure: Alright, alright, I'll wash them.
Shure:  哎呦呦呦呦
Shure: Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Shure:  帮我拿点谢谢
Shure: Can you get me something? Thanks.
Shure:  愁死了
Shure: This is so frustrating.
Shure:  什什么喝完酒还要刷杯子呀
Shure: Why do we have to wash cups after drinking?
Shure:  卧槽这是
Shure: Damn, this is...
Alice: 啊这还有俩锅
Alice: Ah, there are still two pots here.
Shure:  杨老板给我结double工资
Shure: Jake, pay me double salary.
Shure:  不然话我不干了杨老板
Shure: Otherwise, I'm quitting, Jake.
Tasha: 这可不是你能决定的
Tasha: That's not up to you to decide.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 我把这碗拿下拿到楼下刷一下算了
Lucia: I'll take this bowl downstairs to wash it.
Shure:  这碗不是刷完的吗
Shure: Isn't this bowl already washed?
Lucia: 不是要再涮一遍吗
Lucia: Doesn't it need another rinse?
Tasha: 再冲一遍就行了
Tasha: Just rinse it again.
Shure: 你哎
Shure: You...
Tasha: 拿下去
Tasha: Take it down.
Choiszt:  哎再再给我用一下
Choiszt: Hey, let me use it again.
Tasha: 旁边还有洗洁精吗
Tasha: Is there any dish soap left?
Choiszt:  不要了
Choiszt: No need.
Alice: 有点难受了
Alice: I'm feeling a bit uncomfortable.
Alice: 热热的
Alice: It's so hot.
Tasha: 不知道明天干嘛
Tasha: No idea what to do tomorrow.
Katrina:  明天干嘛
Katrina: What to do tomorrow?
Katrina:  我要写小本了
Katrina: I need to write my notebook.
Alice: 明天搓麻将
Alice: Let's play mahjong tomorrow.
Alice: 我能不能看着搓啊
Alice: Can I just watch you guys play?
Tasha: 看着搓什么意思
Tasha: What do you mean by watching?
Alice:就看着别人打
Alice: Just watching others play.
Tasha: 也可以呢
Tasha: That's fine.
Alice:凑够四个人很简单的吧
Alice: It's easy to find four people, right?
Tasha: 应该吧
Tasha: Should be.
Tasha: 不知道谁打呢
Tasha: Not sure who's playing though.
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  现在是期中考试月
Katrina: It's midterm exam month now.
Shure:  你们还有期中考试吗
Shure: Do you guys still have midterms?
Katrina:  没有看我学弟他们发的朋友圈
Katrina: No, look at my junior's WeChat moments.
Katrina:  他们在痛苦我在快乐
Katrina: They're suffering, and I'm enjoying myself.
Shure:  都多大了还还期中考试呢
Shure: How old are you and still have midterms?
Katrina:  我是一个爱学习的乖宝宝
Katrina: I'm a good kid who loves to study.
Shure:  你是一个爱学习的人
Shure: You're someone who loves to study.
Katrina:  哈哈哈气死我了
Katrina: Hahaha, I'm dying from laughter.
Shure:  我是一个爱学习的人
Shure: I'm someone who loves to study.
Katrina:  我是一个爱学习的乖宝
Katrina: I'm a good kid who loves to study.
Katrina:  整点music
Katrina: Let's play some music.
Shure:  什么什么时候扫房间啊
Shure: When are you going to clean the room?
Shure:  快扫房间
Shure: Hurry up and clean the room.
Shure:  然后把这个眼镜摘了
Shure: And take off those glasses.
Alice: 嗯这
Alice: Um, this...
Alice: 需要
Alice: Needs...
Katrina:  你去跟老板介绍一下
Katrina: Go introduce yourself to the boss.
Katrina:  吹一下
Katrina: Impress him.
Katrina:  听过这个卢广冢的歌吗
Katrina: Have you heard of Lu Guangzhong's songs?
Shure: 谁
Shure: Who?
Katrina:  卢广冢
Katrina: Lu Guangzhong.
Shure:  听过
Shure: I've heard of him.
Katrina:  哎哎我这平板那个音效特好
Katrina: Hey, my tablet has amazing sound effects.
Katrina:  4个
Katrina: There are four.
Alice:却又消失不见
Alice: And then it just disappears.
Katrina:  学习一点没干
Katrina: I haven't done any studying.
Lucia: 啥意思这从
Lucia: What do you mean from...
Lucia: 哦这从有抹布
Lucia: Oh, there's a cloth.
Katrina:  我靠跟音响一样
Katrina: Damn, it sounds like a speaker.
Shure:  走去楼下听去
Shure: Let's go downstairs to listen.
Katrina:  楼下咋了
Katrina: What's downstairs?
Katrina:  PK一下你的音响跟我的平板吗
Katrina: Are we going to compare your speaker with my tablet?
Shure:  开玩笑那两个独立单元跟你这个比
Shure: Are you kidding? Those two separate units compared to yours?
Katrina:  哈哈哈我这一个这一个
Katrina: Hahaha, this one here, this one.
Shure:  喝点嘛喝点嘛
Shure: Have a drink, have a drink.
Katrina:  又想套我话是不是哈哈哈
Katrina: You're trying to get me to talk, aren't you? Hahaha.
Shure:  喝点喝点来来来
Shure: Have a drink, have a drink, come on, come on.
Katrina: 不
Katrina: No.
Katrina:  今天晚上还有东西要干呢
Katrina: I still have things to do tonight.
Shure:  我24号交毕设
Shure: I have to submit my graduation project on the 24th.
Shure:  你几号交毕设
Shure: When do you have to submit yours?
Katrina:  你论文写完了吗
Katrina: Have you finished your thesis?
Shure:  写差不多了
Shure: Almost done.
Katrina:  呀怎么切了呀给我
Katrina: Why did you cut it? Give it to me.
Katrina:  这什么老歌
Katrina: What’s this old song?
Katrina:  林志炫的
Katrina: It's by Terry Lin.
Katrina:  我要去把楼下那个to do list写一下
Katrina: I need to write the to-do list downstairs.
Shure:  to do list是吗
Shure: The to-do list, right?
Katrina:  明天
Katrina: Tomorrow.
Lucia: 我靠嘞
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Katrina:  成为一个自带BGM的女生
Katrina: Become a girl with her own BGM.
Shure:  哇哦
Shure: Wow.
Katrina:  明天干什么呀
Katrina: What are we doing tomorrow?
Shure:  杨老板我们什么时候扫房间啊
Shure: Jake, when are we cleaning the room?
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Alice: 好大的油味
Alice: The smell of oil is so strong.
Lucia: 对这个怎么处理我也在想
Lucia: Yeah, I’m also wondering how to deal with it.
Alice:洗洁精
Alice: Dish soap.
Lucia: 碗反正现在都搞了
Lucia: The bowls, anyway, are all done now.
Alice: 这些都好了
Alice: These are all done.
Alice:那我放进去了
Alice: I’ll put them in.
Lucia: 你说咱还有
Lucia: Do we still have any...
Alice: 哎呦妈呀
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Alice:这个刷了吗
Alice: Has this been scrubbed?
Lucia: 呃我不知道
Lucia: Uh, I don't know.
Lucia: 因为我只第二遍的那个碗
Lucia: Because I only did the second round of the bowls.
Lucia: 这个我也不清楚不清楚是谁洗的这个也要
Lucia: I'm not sure, not sure who cleaned this one. It needs to be done again.
Lucia: 再弄一遍
Lucia: Do it again.
Lucia: 要不把它再
Lucia: Or maybe just wipe it off. Look at this.
Lucia: 擦就算了你看这
Lucia: It's not even...
Lucia: 都没那啥
Lucia: ... properly cleaned.
Alice:我们现在没有
Alice: We don't have...
Alice: 我现在没有
Alice: I don't have...
Alice: 我们现在没有那个洗洁精了这会
Alice: We don't have any more dish soap right now.
Lucia: 拿下去了是吗
Lucia: Did you take it down?
Alice: 对所以就这样吧
Alice: Yeah, so just leave it.
Lucia: 这是啥这是油污净
Lucia: What’s this? Is this grease cleaner?
Lucia: 这是不是可以用来洗那个啥
Lucia: Can this be used for washing?
Alice: 这是
Alice: This is...
Alice:洗这行吗这好像是
Alice: Can we use this? Seems like...
Alice: 清洁除胶
Alice: ...it's adhesive remover.
Alice: 这个是可以弄这个的
Alice: This one can be used for this.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 洗池子碗应该不行
Lucia: But it's probably not okay to wash the sink with it.
Lucia: 碗估计是不行
Lucia: I guess it's not okay for the bowl either.
Alice:这还没拆开呢
Alice: This hasn't been opened yet.
Lucia: 这个碗看起来也不怎么干净
Lucia: This bowl doesn't look very clean either.
Lucia: 这个嘞
Lucia: This one...
Lucia: 这怎么一捏就是油的呀
Lucia: Why does it feel greasy when I squeeze it?
Alice: 今天几点结束呢
Alice: When does this end today?
Tasha: 好像说很快
Tasha: I think they said soon.
Tasha: 等录完房间就结束了
Tasha: It ends after we finish recording the room.
Alice: 不还要交换礼物吗
Alice: But we still have to exchange gifts, right?
Tasha: 哦
Alice: 还有两个锅
Alice: There are still two pots left.
Tasha: 歇会吧
Tasha: Let's take a break.
Tasha: 他们都开始在楼下唱歌了
Tasha: They're all starting to sing downstairs.
Alice: 但是这剩下来的那个什么还没清洁呢
Alice: But there's still some stuff left that hasn't been cleaned.
Lucia: 我在想这个锅
Lucia: I'm thinking about this pot.
Lucia: 这锅看起来太大了
Lucia: This pot looks too big.
Lucia: 怎么都放不到那里边这怎么
Lucia: How can we fit it in there?
Alice:是
Alice:洗洁精是不是也下去了
Alice: Did the dish soap run out too?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Alice:怎么说这锅原来在哪来着
Alice: By the way, where did this pot come from originally?
Alice:上边还是下边
Alice: From the top or bottom?
Tasha: 就可以放这在下面但是也可以放上面
Tasha: It can go on the bottom, but it can also go on the top.
Tasha: 放哪都行其实
Tasha: You can put it anywhere, actually.
Alice: 好累呀
Alice: I'm so tired.
Tasha: 这是真唱吗
Tasha: Are they really singing?
Alice: 不知道听不出来
Alice: I don't know, I can't tell.
Alice: 表 达很快乐
Alice: They're expressing happiness.
Lucia: 我们接下来要干嘛呀
Lucia: What are we doing next?
Tasha: 那就在楼上躺一会吧
Tasha: Let's go lie down upstairs for a bit.
Tasha: 哈哈在楼上摸鱼
Tasha: Haha, let's slack off upstairs.
Tasha: 先摸会鱼吧
Tasha: Let's slack off for a while first.
Tasha: 他女朋友送他手串怎么不带了
Tasha: Why isn't he wearing the bracelet his girlfriend gave him?
Alice:是他女朋友送的吗
Alice: Did his girlfriend give it to him?
Alice: ：他不说女生吗
Alice: Didn't he say it was from a girl?
Alice:啊可能是女朋友
Alice: Ah, maybe it is from his girlfriend.
Tasha: 对啊啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice: 啊女朋友吗
Alice: Ah, his girlfriend?
Lucia: 那可能就是这个对话发生的时候
Lucia: Then maybe that's when this conversation happened.
Lucia: 你不在
Lucia: You're not here.
Lucia: 你可能没听到
Lucia: You might not have heard it.
Alice: 我就听见一个女生朋友随便送的
Alice: I just heard that a female friend casually gave it.
Alice:交换礼物是抽吗我会抽到谁呢
Alice: Is the gift exchange by drawing? Who will I draw?
Alice:小礼物
Alice: A small gift.
Lucia: 我发现快递到咱们这还挺慢的我现在在想
Lucia: I noticed deliveries are quite slow here. I'm thinking...
Lucia: 我东西现在下单还能不能到
Lucia: If I place an order now, will it arrive on time?
Lucia: 因为我有好些还没还没那什么
Lucia: Because I still have quite a few things that haven't... you know.
Alice: 我们都还没有买
Alice: We haven't bought anything yet.
Lucia: 我光挑了对我今天光挑了一下
Lucia: I just picked out a few things today.
Lucia: 加了好些购物车但是都没有那个啥
Lucia: Added a lot to my cart but haven't actually ordered.
Alice: 明天是不是要录麻将
Alice: Are we recording Mahjong tomorrow?
Tasha: 可能吧
Tasha: Maybe.
Tasha: 感觉每天都会说
Tasha: Seems like we say it every day.
Tasha: 但是每天都不执行
Tasha: But we never actually do it.
Tasha: 因为感觉大家都很难启动的样子
Tasha: Because it feels like everyone has a hard time getting started.
Lucia: 大家都是p人
Lucia: Everyone's just procrastinating.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 我昨天本来想着口红今天就要讨论
Lucia: I was thinking about lipstick yesterday and we were supposed to discuss it today.
Lucia: 出大概装修成什么样
Lucia: About how it should be decorated.
Lucia: 然后今天就要开始下单了
Lucia: And start ordering today.
Lucia: 但今天好像也没有讨
Lucia: But it seems like we didn't discuss anything specific today either.
Lucia: 就是具体的讨论我也没发
Lucia: And I haven't sent...
Alice:今天周三了是吗四五六
Alice: It's Wednesday today, right? Thursday, Friday, Saturday...
Alice:四五六周日不就happy了
Alice: Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Sunday, and then it's happy time.
Alice: 嗯周周一啊
Alice: Hmm, Monday then.
Alice: 这这几天挺快的
Alice: These days are going by pretty fast.
Alice: 好烫好难受
Alice: It's so hot, it's unbearable.
Lucia: 所以他如果周日才到的话就很紧张
Lucia: So if it arrives on Sunday, it'll be really tight.
Lucia: 必须要周六的时候到
Lucia: It has to arrive by Saturday.
Lucia: 但是今天已经17号了我承认明天181920
Lucia: But today is already the 17th. I admit, tomorrow is 18, 19, 20...
Jake: 哈喽
Jake: Hello.
Lucia: 哈喽
Lucia: Hello.
Alice: 还有两个锅
Alice: There are two more pots.
Tasha: 就只剩两个锅了
Tasha: Only two pots left.
Alice: 还有一个池子
Alice: And one sink.
Jake: 还有一个池子
Jake: And one sink.
Alice:嗯池子用威猛先啊啊生
Alice: Yeah, use the powerful cleaner for the sink.
Lucia: 池子
Lucia: The sink.
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or...
Alice:池子用这个就行了
Alice: The sink can be cleaned with this.
Alice: 有威猛先生
Alice: There's Mr. Muscle.
Lucia: 但是我但是我在想那个锅
Lucia: But I'm thinking about the pot.
Lucia: 因为那锅好像放不进来
Lucia: Because the pot seems too big to fit in.
Jake:哦就是准备泡一泡是吧还是啥
Jake: Oh, so you plan to soak it for a while or what?
Alice: 这个就全是清洁吗
Alice: Is this just for cleaning?
Jake: 那锅能擦干净吗
Jake: Can the pot be cleaned?
Lucia: 这个应该不能洗锅这只能洗
Lucia: This can't be used to clean the pot, it can only clean...
Alice:这个只能用来擦厨房表面
Alice: This can only be used to wipe the kitchen surfaces.
Lucia: 现在现在洗洁精好像在楼下是吧
Lucia: Now, the dish soap seems to be downstairs, right?
Alice: 他为什么连个喷头都没有啊
Alice: Why doesn't it even have a spray nozzle?
Lucia: 感觉非常的宽
Lucia: It feels very spacious.
Lucia: 看是
Lucia: Look, it is.
Alice:擦应该擦不干净
Alice: Wiping it probably won't get it clean.
Lucia: 就就是他对不太准
Lucia: It's just not accurate.
Lucia: 那个什么
Lucia: That, uh...
Lucia: 擦咱能把它擦明白吗
Lucia: Can we even get it clean by wiping?
Jake:试试
Jake: Try it.
Alice:洗洁精在下面
Alice: The dish soap is downstairs.
Lucia: 把它擦一下
Lucia: Wipe it a bit.
Lucia: 然后直接用水冲冲就完事了
Lucia: Then just rinse it with water and we're done.
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 这个都洗好了
Alice: This is all cleaned.
Lucia: 我觉得好像也能擦个七七八八
Lucia: I think it can be cleaned quite well.
Lucia: 我们是不是不应该说那个F2word
Lucia: Shouldn't we avoid saying the F-word?
Lucia: 哈哈哈没有没有
Lucia: Haha, no, no.
Lucia: 我刚才感叹了一句
Lucia: I just exclaimed.
Lucia: 那个f word
Lucia: The F-word.
Alice:好累啊
Alice: So tired.
Alice: 不想弄了
Alice: I don't want to do it anymore.
Lucia: 这真的很勉强
Lucia: This is really a struggle.
Alice:我觉得还是得用洗洁精
Alice: I think we still need to use dish soap.
Alice: 你把它拿上来
Alice: You bring it up.
Lucia: 也行啊
Lucia: Okay, sure.
Alice: 还要把他拿下去
Alice: We still need to bring it down.
Lucia: 还是拿洗洁精算了这锅什么的这么大咱要把两个搬下去吗
Lucia: Let's just use the dish soap, the pot is so big, are we going to move both down?
Alice:那我下去拿吧
Alice: I'll go down and get it.
Lucia: 这个要纯粹用这个还是
Lucia: Should we use just this or...
Alice:你的无菌手套在哪
Alice: Where are your sterile gloves?
Tasha: 在那个冰箱上
Tasha: On top of the fridge.
Jake: 擦完了
Jake: Finished wiping.
Alice:还没有
Alice: Not yet.
Jake: 摇骰子吧
Jake: Let's roll the dice.
Tasha: 谁大谁先挑
Tasha: Whoever rolls higher picks first.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Okay.
Alice:挑啥呀
Alice: What are we picking?
Tasha: 挑礼物摇骰子
Tasha: Picking gifts, rolling the dice.
Alice:挑礼物
Alice: Picking gifts.
Lucia: 鉴于我的礼物是个小choker
Lucia: Given that my gift is a small choker,
Lucia: 所以我认为男生如果抽到的话
Lucia: I think if a guy gets it,
Lucia: 并没有什么
Lucia: it wouldn't matter.
Tasha: choker
Tasha: Choker.
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 这怎么是烂的
Alice: How is this bad?
Jake: 这样吧你们下去聊聊明天的计划
Jake: How about this, you guys go downstairs and discuss tomorrow's plan.
Tasha: 明天干嘛
Tasha: What about tomorrow?
Jake: 对明天户外
Jake: Yeah, tomorrow's outdoor.
Tasha: 户外
Tasha: Outdoor?
Jake: 采采风
Jake: Taking a stroll.
Tasha: 采什么风
Tasha: Taking a stroll?
Jake: 拍拍照片
Jake: Taking photos.
Jake: 玩一玩
Jake: Having fun.
Tasha: 这样吗
Tasha: Really?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 游客照吗
Lucia: Tourist photos?
Tasha: 野餐吗
Tasha: Picnic?
Jake: 呃最后一天可能放点短片什么的
Jake: Uh, maybe we'll show some short films on the last day.
Jake: 其实
Jake: Actually,
Jake: 原来想要有一个剧本结果好像也没有
Jake: I originally wanted a script but it seems we don't have one.
Jake: 什么剧本
Jake: What script?
Lucia: 不是您不是有个剧本吗
Lucia: Didn't you have a script?
Tasha: 您不是有个备用剧本吗
Tasha: Didn't you have a backup script?
Tasha: 那要不我们现在找一个剧本
Tasha: How about we find a script now,
Tasha: 然后我们开演吧
Tasha: and then we can start?
Tasha: 对就这种只需要本性出演即可
Tasha: Yeah, just something where we can act as ourselves.
Lucia: 你知道韩国有一个
Lucia: You know in Korea, there's a thing where
Lucia: 就是比如说比如说你是假设你是你是
Lucia: like, let's say for example you are, let's say you are,
Lucia: 你是j人
Lucia: you are person J,
Lucia: 然后我是p人
Lucia: and I'm person P,
Lucia: 然后我们俩比如说在讨论某个问题
Lucia: and we are discussing a certain issue.
Lucia: 然后就是j人可能就是呃呃
Lucia: And then, people like J might, um, um
Lucia: 大概率会有什么什么样的看法
Lucia: Most likely have some kind of opinion
Lucia: 然后p人
Lucia: Then people like P
Lucia: 大概率会有什么什么样的看法
Lucia: Most likely have some kind of opinion
Lucia: 对就是但是他是以一种就是
Lucia: Yeah, but it's not in a very stereotypical or academic way
Lucia: 不是那么很刻板和学术
Lucia: It actually has a context
Lucia: 他确实会有一个语境
Lucia: For example,
Lucia: 比如说啊
Lucia: Like,
Lucia: 我们三个围在一起吃火锅啊什么的
Lucia: The three of us are having hotpot together or something
Lucia: 然后突然聊到什么问题
Lucia: And suddenly we talk about something
Lucia: 然后比如说就是
Lucia: And for example, like,
Lucia: 就是因为
Lucia: Like,
Lucia: 比如说那个今天的月亮好圆啊
Lucia: For example, today the moon is so round
Lucia: 不是表白的时候经常用的一句话吗
Lucia: Isn't that a common phrase used in confessions?
Lucia: 或者什么
Lucia: Or something like,
Lucia: 我想跟你看今天的月亮怎么怎么样
Lucia: I want to watch the moon with you tonight
Lucia: 然后就是如果是t人的话
Lucia: And then, if it's people like T
Lucia: 就会觉得啊
Lucia: They might think,
Lucia: 为什么要说这句话
Lucia: Why would you say that?
Lucia: 然后如果是f人的话
Lucia: And if it's people like F
Lucia: 就会很快get到
Lucia: They would quickly get it
Lucia: 然后觉得啊好浪漫什么的这种
Lucia: And think, oh, how romantic and stuff
Lucia: 就是如果有
Lucia: So if there is,
Lucia: 比如说有类似的这样的剧本的话
Lucia: For example, a script similar to this
Lucia: 我们可以按照他随便演一下
Lucia: We can just act it out casually
Lucia: 就
Lucia: Like,
Lucia: 如果我们实在找不到什么别的XTV剧
Lucia: If we really can't find any other XTV shows
Tasha: 也可以啊
Tasha: That works too
Tasha: 我以为是要演电视剧
Tasha: I thought we were going to act in a TV drama
Jake: 就是室内
Jake: It's like indoor
Jake: 就不是室内的activity吧
Jake: It's not an indoor activity, right?
Jake: 本身就是一个
Jake: It's actually like a
Jake: 叫什么生活类数据集
Jake: What do you call it, a lifestyle data set
Jake: 对爱干啥都行
Jake: Yeah, you can do whatever you want
Jake: 最后只要能联系上就行
Jake: As long as you can connect it in the end
Tasha: 哦爱打游戏行吗
Tasha: Oh, is playing games okay?
Jake: 你得跳着舞打
Jake: You have to dance while playing
Lucia: 健身环哈哈哈
Lucia: Fitness Ring, haha
Tasha: 健身房里面玩金铲铲啊
Tasha: Playing Golden Shovel in the gym?
Lucia: 没有我说的是switch那个健身环
Lucia: No, I mean the Fitness Ring on Switch
Lucia: 我们有个地点吗
Lucia: Do we have a location?
Lucia: 周围有啥
Lucia: What's around?
Jake:对有个公园
Jake: Yeah, there's a park.
Lucia: 公园
Lucia: A park.
Lucia: 有多大呀能玩一天吗哈哈哈
Lucia: How big is it? Can we play there all day? Hahaha.
Lucia: 所以我们可以在公园里面再来一次
Lucia: So we can do it again in the park.
Lucia: 破冰游戏
Lucia: Icebreaker games.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:也可以啊
Jake: Sure, we can.
Tasha: 既然大家都是研究生了
Tasha: Since we're all grad students,
Tasha: 那我们就玩一些
Tasha: Let's play something...
Lucia: 那我们就互相研究研究研究
Lucia: Let's research each other.
Lucia: 哦还可以
Lucia: Oh, that works too.
Katrina:  我们开始扫了吗
Katrina: Are we starting the scan?
Jake: 对可以扫
Jake: Yes, we can scan.
Lucia: 飞花令
Lucia: Feihualing.
Katrina:  可以扫我房间
Katrina: You can scan my room.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh man.
Tasha: 你会玩吗
Tasha: Do you know how to play?
Jake: 害怕
Jake: Scared.
Katrina:  什么飞花令
Katrina: What's Feihualing?
Katrina:  明天的游戏吗
Katrina: Tomorrow's game?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 明天的游戏
Lucia: Tomorrow's game.
Jake: 对明天再再琢磨整点啥
Jake: Yeah, we'll figure out what to do tomorrow.
Lucia: 用古诗词飞吗
Lucia: Using ancient poems?
Lucia: 还是飞什么
Lucia: Or what?
Katrina:  古诗词我不行
Katrina: I'm not good at ancient poems.
Tasha: 不然用什么飞
Tasha: What else could we use?
Lucia: 哈哈这个这个
Lucia: Haha, this game...
Lucia: 游戏不是
Lucia: Is now...
Lucia: 现在
Lucia: Already...
Lucia: 已经扩展到各种各样的游戏领域了
Lucia: Expanded into all sorts of game fields.
Lucia: 比如不出来
Lucia: For instance...
Lucia: 哈哈啊
Lucia: Haha, well...
Lucia: 比如不出来
Lucia: For instance...
Lucia: 因为你问住我了
Lucia: Because you stumped me.
Tasha: 你说已经扩展到各个领域了
Tasha: You said it expanded into all fields.
Tasha: 我就想问问扩展到哪些领域了
Tasha: So I want to know which fields exactly.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 一会就是我要扫房间
Jake: In a bit, I need to sweep the room.
Jake: 然后你们可以
Jake: Then you guys can...
Jake: 我先扫楼上
Jake: I'll sweep upstairs first.
Jake: 然后你们可以先下楼去讨论
Jake: Then you guys can go downstairs and discuss.
Jake: 然后我扫楼下的时候你们再上来啊
Jake: When I sweep downstairs, you can come up.
Tasha: 就是不能有人是吧
Tasha: So no one can be here, right?
Jake:就是我的
Jake: Yes, within the range of my phone, no one can be there.
Jake: 手机的范围里面不能有人
Jake: Within the range of my phone, no one can be there.
Lucia: 扫之前跟我说一声
Lucia: Let me know before you start sweeping.
Lucia: 因为我要把那边挂两件衣服拿出去
Lucia: Because I need to take out the two clothes hanging there.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 那我要不然我还能挂着两件湿衣服很奇怪
Lucia: Otherwise, it'll be weird to leave two wet clothes hanging.
Jake: 对对对那两件可能就哈哈哈
Jake: Right, right, those two could just... hahaha
Jake: 这就相当于是
Jake: It's like...
Jake: 这个屋子里边固有的财产了
Jake: It's like part of the permanent property of this house.
Lucia: 哈哈哈就把它拿出来
Lucia: Hahaha, let's just take them out.
Lucia: 然后就就就基本上只剩下箱子和包了
Lucia: Then basically, only the boxes and bags are left.
Lucia: 别的我都塞进去了
Lucia: I've put everything else away.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 成语接龙
Tasha: Chinese idiom game.
Tasha: 你画我猜
Tasha: Draw and guess.
Lucia: 真心话大冒险
Lucia: Truth or dare.
Lucia: 没有奖惩机制啊
Lucia: There's no reward or punishment system.
Tasha: 我说输的人喝
Tasha: I say the loser drinks.
Lucia: 我以为是奖励赢的人喝
Lucia: I thought the winner drinks as a reward.
Lucia: 惩罚输的人喝酒呢
Lucia: Punish the loser to drink alcohol.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Tasha: 怎么啦
Tasha: What's up?
Alice: 呵呵充电宝掉了
Alice: Haha, my power bank fell.
Tasha: 充电宝
Tasha: Power bank?
Alice: 这我腰里别着呢
Alice: I had it clipped to my waist.
Alice: 因为我没有兜
Alice: Because I don't have pockets.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 没事我扶着呢你可以粘一粘好
Lucia: It's okay, I'll hold it for you, you can stick it on properly.
Alice:你往上捋一下对
Alice: Lift it up, right.
Alice: 啊可以可以
Alice: Ah, okay, okay.
Alice:让我那个松紧带箍着他
Alice: Let me adjust the elastic band to hold it.
Alice: 我把裙子往下拽一点让他箍着就行
Alice: I'll pull my skirt down a bit so it can hold it.
Lucia: 哎别我捏着捏着充电宝给他捏
Lucia: Hey, don't, I'll hold it, give it to me.
Lucia: 关机了
Lucia: It's turned off.
Alice: 算了给他弄弄掉吧不要了断了
Alice: Forget it, just get rid of it. No need, cut it off.
Alice: 对
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 嗯好了
Lucia: Hmm, alright.
Alice: 不用了OK
Alice: No need, okay.
Lucia: 那我就先征用这个充电宝好了
Lucia: Then I'll just borrow this power bank for now.
Lucia: 我看一眼我那个还有多少电能发现
Lucia: Let me check how much battery I have left.
Katrina:  通州攻略哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Tongzhou strategy, hahaha.
Shure:  然后一搜全是环球影城
Shure: And when you search, it's all Universal Studios.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Katrina:  笑死我了
Katrina: This is killing me.
Jake:就是一会的扫描活动都在吗
Jake: So, everyone ready for the scanning activity later?
Jake: OK一会的扫描活动就是我在下面扫
Jake: Okay, for the scanning activity later, I'll be scanning downstairs.
Jake: 然后我下面扫完之后
Jake: And after I finish scanning downstairs,
Jake: 呃我会躲在一个房间里面
Jake: Uh, I'll hide in a room.
Katrina:  然后我们去找你
Katrina: And then we go find you.
Jake: 然后我为了不扫到人
Jake: And to avoid scanning people,
Jake: 所以说我会在里面待着
Jake: I'll be staying inside.
Jake: 然后我让刘帅下来叫你们
Jake: Then I'll have Choiszt come down to get you guys.
Jake: 然后但是我不能扫到你们对吧
Jake: But I can't scan you guys, right?
Jake: 嗯所以说你们也要躲在一个房间里面
Jake: So, you also need to hide in a room.
Jake: 就你们得躲在就你们就躲在
Jake: You need to hide, just hide.
Jake: 你们就在你们就室外吧
Jake: You guys stay outside.
Jake: 好吧好对
Jake: Alright, yeah.
Choiszt: 一楼扫完了他们不都去一楼都可以去一楼
Choiszt: Once the first floor is scanned, they can all go to the first floor.
Jake: 就是我上楼的时候不能扫到人
Jake: When I go upstairs, I can't scan anyone.
Jake: 我上楼的时候你们在
Jake: When I go upstairs, you guys...
Jake: 对对对对嗯
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, yeah.
Jake: 然后你们在这就聊一聊明天的安排吧
Jake: And then you can talk about tomorrow's plans.
Choiszt: 反正我叫他们下去他们就下去藏好
Choiszt: Anyway, when I call them down, they'll hide.
Jake: 对你们就你们
Jake: Yeah, you guys...
Jake: 就就就出门就好
Jake: Just, just go outside.
Jake: 你们也可以
Jake: You can also...
Jake: 现在在外边都都行
Jake: Stay outside now, it's fine.
Jake: 总之就是我不能扫到人
Jake: Anyway, I can't scan anyone.
Jake: 你们聊一聊啊
Jake: Talk amongst yourselves.
Jake: 明天安排多多
Jake: About tomorrow's schedule, discuss more.
Jake: 多交流多交流
Jake: Talk more, talk more.
Katrina:  西海子公园
Katrina: Xihai Park.
Jake: 多交流
Jake: Talk more.
Jake: 反正明天大概是就是就是在户外
Jake: Anyway, tomorrow is mostly outdoors.
Jake: 然后加点压花什么的对吧
Jake: Then add some embossing, right?
Jake: 这个
Jake: This
Jake: 多说话啊多说话
Jake: Talk more, talk more.
Shure:  多交流的方式是什么
Shure: What's a good way to communicate more?
Shure:  多喝酒就多
Shure: Drink more and...
Shure:  交流了哈哈
Shure: Communicate more, haha.
Lucia: 边喝边唠嗑啊
Lucia: Drink and chat at the same time.
Lucia: 那咱整两盅
Lucia: Let's have a couple of drinks.
Katrina: 浓密延长其实都差不多了
Katrina: Lengthening and thickening are pretty much the same.
Katrina: 而且我估计你女朋友也不是很懂就截给你了
Katrina: Plus, I guess your girlfriend doesn't really get it, so she just sent it to you.
Lucia: 我看一眼还有些啥
Lucia: Let me take a look at what else is there.
Shure:  其实就是
Shure: Actually...
Shure:  刚才把你的橙汁换成了葡萄汁
Shure: I just swapped your orange juice with grape juice.
Shure:  他基本就是只喝了一口而已
Shure: He basically just took a sip.
Tasha: 我不是你可以尝尝啊
Tasha: I’m not, you can try it.
Tasha: 我刚术后一个月内不能喝酒
Tasha: I can't drink alcohol for a month after surgery.
Tasha:但是 我没有忍住然后喝了一点
Tasha: But I couldn't resist and had a little.
Tasha: 然后我慢慢喝就行
Tasha: So, I'll drink slowly.
Lucia: 我喝一下你介意吗
Lucia: Mind if I take a sip?
Katrina:  纤长浓密浓巧三个
Katrina: Lengthening, thickening, and dense, those three.
Lucia: 其实我也不介意但是有的会介意一般会先问一下
Lucia: Actually, I don't mind, but some people do, so it's better to ask first.
Lucia: 你这个屏幕好酷啊
Lucia: Your screen is so cool!
Lucia: 是像素哎
Lucia: It's pixelated!
Lucia: 那这些羊如果你不管他他会消失吗
Lucia: If you don't take care of these sheep, will they disappear?
Lucia: 那你不断的点岂不是就会有很多很多的羊
Lucia: So if you keep clicking, won't there be a lot of sheep?
Shure:  嗯就是
Shure: Yeah, it’s like...
Katrina:  然后当时我就是属于呃
Katrina: Back then, I didn't want to reply, nor did I want to block.
Katrina:  就是不想回也不想拉黑
Katrina: It could be related to the version.
Katrina:  哦也有可能跟版本有关
Katrina: Oh, it might be a version issue.
Katrina:  但是这个牌子是日本牌子呀
Katrina: But this brand is Japanese.
Shure:  潘家园跟北新桥离多远呢
Shure: How far is Panjiayuan from Beixinqiao?
Alice: 哎呦
Alice: Oh no.
Katrina:  这公园有那什么大摆锤什么的玩
Katrina: This park has that giant pendulum ride and stuff.
Katrina: 你们明天还来吗
Katrina: Are you coming again tomorrow?
Katrina:  他说就明天户外
Katrina: He said there's outdoor stuff tomorrow.
Alice: 露西你见我的线了吗
Alice: Lucia, have you seen my thread?
Lucia: 呃在这里
Lucia: Uh, it's here.
Shure:  好困啊
Shure: I'm so sleepy.
Katrina:  我想洗澡呀
Katrina: I want to take a shower.
Shure: 洗过了
Shure: I already did.
Katrina:  就去西海子公园吧
Katrina: Let's go to Xihai Park.
Shure:  唱吧你就
Shure: Just sing.
Katrina:  通利弗尼亚
Katrina: California.
Katrina:  我真笑死
Katrina: I'm really laughing to death.
Alice: 你的手串
Alice: Your bracelet.
Katrina:  还可以划船呢
Katrina: We can also row boats there.
Alice:好累啊
Alice: So tired.
Katrina:  哎北京好适合带富士相机
Katrina: Oh, Beijing is perfect for taking pictures with Fujifilm cameras.
Shure:  是的我跟你讲
Shure: Yes, I'm telling you.
Tasha: 拍出来很好看
Tasha: The photos come out so nice.
Tasha: 好烦呀嗯
Tasha: So annoying, hmm.
Katrina:  这一两个地方差不多够了
Katrina: These one or two places are enough.
Katrina:  因为等我们出门估计又2点多然后
Katrina: Because by the time we leave, it'll probably be past 2 PM and...
Katrina:  这公园还挺漂亮
Katrina: This park is really pretty.
Katrina:  OK就西海子公园
Katrina: Okay, let's go to Xihai Park.
Shure:  你就拉着人家唱你这个你你唱的歌吧
Shure: You just make people sing your songs, right?
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  他们听过这歌吗
Shure: Have they heard this song before?